[Music]
good evening
i'm stuart brand from the long now
foundation
i'm here to introduce the long short
and also to report something that bears
relation to this seminar series
i'm working on a book the book is called
maintenance
i think of it as kind of a long now
project
long-term thinking is in the thick of
maintenance it has to do with managing
continuity
and it's kind of an ambitious book the
subtitle is
of everything
which means that i'm researching a whole
bunch of areas that i
up to now knew little about other than
interest
and it's pretty intense so and i'm
having such a good time
one byproduct of that is i'm backing out
of some of the other activities that i
would otherwise be engaging in
immersion in the book for probably
already a year probably two more years
maybe more
and so i am stepping back a ways on
curating this series
and it is being done uh increasingly by
alexander rose and kevin kelly
and indeed you'll see the first example
of the new regime tonight since it's
purely curated by
alexander brower she'll be doing the q a
and so on
good evening
as i read bina's book about
uh really that's just this fundamental
book about long-term thinking
every chapter felt like a book that that
really we should have written ourselves
um and it has so many great references
to speakers
um that have been on this stage some of
our own board members like danny stewart
peter schwartz
and so it's also i think in being in
january having
uh having a book that that you can
really kind of hang
your your code on and say well what do
you mean by long-term thinking how do i
do it in my
own life and i think that's the thing
that she's captured better than than we
have
uh yet really with any project that long
now so i'm very excited
to have her here tonight um she spent
at least five years almost seven years
working on this project
and i'm super excited to have her here
tonight to share with you
hello everyone and thank you xander
so that clock the clock of the long now
when i first heard about it it was a
source of inspiration for me
as someone who's interested in long-term
thinking and ended up writing a book
about it
and i remember hearing about the long
now foundation and
meeting a member and just wondering sort
of like what is this strange
monastic group that is building a clock
to run for 10 000 years
and this member told me it's kind of
like a support group
for people who are concerned about the
future so
i guess that resonates so maybe the way
i should introduce myself is by saying
hello i'm bina and i've been a heavy
long-term thinker for
as long as i can remember
thank you thank you anyone else anyone
else
[Applause]
so i uh i want to start at the end
of a civilization so these are people
preserved in the ash
of mount vesuvius in 79 a.d
and when the volcano erupted in pompeii
and
destroyed the city of pompei the
civilization that was there in
herculaneum
the people were caught unaware they
didn't really know
that this was about to happen this is
according to the accounts of pliny the
younger who was
the poet who chronicled the eruption
years later he wrote letters describing
that the earth was trembling in the days
before the
eruption but that people didn't really
know
what that was and that that meant that
they should flee
the path of this volcano and in fact
17 years before this volcanic eruption
a lot of people don't realize this
history but there had been a severe
earthquake in campania
in that region of modern day italy and
it had leveled buildings it had killed
flocks of sheep it had cracked statues
of the gods
and the explanations at the time a lot
of people thought of this as some sort
of an angry act of the gods when this
happened but even the most
sort of erudite thinkers of the age
seneca who was probably the most
respected
uh person thinker of that time in rome
he was the
tutor to nero and also an advisor to
nero the emperor
he wrote in natural questions that
earthquakes were
assuredly caused by subterranean winds
that were trying to escape from
the earth and he also reassured people
he said look this region is just as safe
as any other region
there's no reason to evacuate just
because this earthquake happened
go about your lives live live normally
and so i'm struck because i'm here near
to
very active seismic faults that we know
so much more
than the ancients did so we know about
plate tectonics
we have seismic instruments that show us
activity in certain areas measure the
size of earthquakes
we know of course that the region around
mount vesuvius is an active seismic zone
also that there's
active volcano all of this knowledge
and we also have other kinds of
predictive knowledge we
are able to look into the future in a
way that the ancients couldn't have
imagined whether that's our weather
forecast
hurricane forecasts which have gotten
vastly more accurate over the last 50
years
the fact that we know the half-life of
radioactive waste
the fact that we can model and predict
the climate of the future the next 50
years the next 100 years that we can see
how we're warming the planet
and so with all of that knowledge
the question is will we use it to
actually think ahead better and i don't
think
having forecasts having all these better
forecasts are the same as having good
foresight which is to say the judgment
to use those forecasts to make better
decisions about the future
and so the question that's been driving
me and that drove
me to write this book the optimus
telescope is can we do better than the
ancients can we actually use all of the
vast knowledge we have
to act better and and to think ahead
more wisely and i i say that
and not just sort of can we as any
generation but because i think our
generation has a greater responsibility
to think ahead than in
previous generations that we're living
in a reckless age
the people in pompei were kind of
innocents they were not that different
from the dinosaurs that were struck by
the meteorite
they didn't know right that this was
about to happen
but that will be hard for people to say
about us with all the knowledge we have
so how can we actually do better in a
time where
we're driven a lot by instant
gratification our culture is reinforcing
the immediate whether it's how you look
at our news cycles or our consumer
products
or even just how we measure progress in
businesses whether we look at quarterly
profits or how we look at
you know whether how much we've
accomplished in a year
so all of that is the context that sort
of set me out uh
i've traveled around the world over the
course of the five years i was
researching and writing this book
looking for examples of where people do
think ahead
where people have failed to think ahead
and to try to understand why
i looked at fields of research spanning
anthropology economics
evolutionary biology and interviewed
experts
of all kinds including some who are here
in this room like stuart and danny
hillis
who of course is along with alexander
the engineer behind the clock that's
going to run for 10 000 years that we
hope is going to run for 10 000 years
and that all kind of led me to this
conclusion
that i i don't know if we're going to be
able to think ahead
uh but i think we can and i have some
optimism about our ability to think
ahead
and to do better than the ancients and i
want to share with you i guess sort of
four reasons
across this talk why i have that
optimism about our ability to think
ahead
the first is that we are more than our
biological impulses
so i think it's a common misconception
conception that we are just like the
hunter-gatherers on the plains
and that we are programmed to think just
short-term
we're programmed to respond to our
immediate impulses and not do a whole
lot more
now all of you are in this room and
you're kind of a testament to the fact
that that is not
the only thing we're capable of as human
beings because you all
at least to some degree care about
long-term thinking and are probably
doing it to some degree in your lives
and of course if we look across human
history we are also the species that
started farming in the fertile crescent
right we're also the species that built
civilizations that have put human beings
on
the moon and maybe someday on mars so we
know we have the capacity
to some degree for this long-term
thinking but there's also this sort of
sense that we are just programmed
and we're not much more than than our
biology when it comes to our immediate
needs and are seeking of instant
gratification
what i found in my research for this
book is that culture and environment
matter a whole lot
when it comes to thinking ahead and can
support us to think ahead in many ways
so many of you will be familiar with the
classic marshmallow test
uh the test given to toddlers uh walter
michelle
starred in the 60s i know he was a
speaker a long-term thinking speaker
assault speaker
uh and um of course he's he's since
passed away
one of the notions that came out of the
sort of popularization of this test
is that there are certain kids who are
really good at
waiting for that second marshmallow they
resist the urge to take the first one
and they they end up doing better in
life right we know that they
pass their sat scores at with higher
school
sorry got higher sat scores uh graduated
from college at higher rates
uh basically succeeded at the game of
life
and that then there are some people who
indulge in that first
treat first marshmallow pretzel cookie
and that they
are just kind of cursed to not being
very good at thinking ahead
so that's kind of the myth i think that
emerged from michelle's original
experiments
which were done i said in the 60s but of
course he followed those students those
kids as they grew up and to see how they
did in life
well the body of research around the
marshmallow test that has come
after those initial experiments really
tells a different story
and it tells a story of how peer groups
and culture
and norms change whether people wait for
the second marshmallow
and one of the examples of this is a
study that was done that showed
that kids who are in groups where
they're wearing all wearing red t-shirts
and they're told kids with the red
t-shirt
wait for the second marshmallow wait for
the second cookie well then those kids
will at much higher rates wait for that
across different kinds of differences
across
different kinds of factors another
really interesting
uh insight from these studies is that
culture can overcome
even scarcity or poverty lack of
resources which we usually associate
with
being more wired for instant
gratification i love
the study of cameroonian toddlers that
compared camerooning toddlers with
german toddlers hundreds of them
and found that the subsistence farmers
kids in cameroon were passing the
marshmallow test
with a local treat known as a puff puff
like a kind of doughnut treat
they were passing it at sort of rates of
70 percent they were waiting for that
second treat whereas german and american
toddlers
routinely when they take the marshmallow
test pass only about 30 percent
pass way for the second treat so some of
our conceptions about who can wait
who can think ahead i think are wrong
and also
some of what we learn is that
environment and culture really matter
and change even what individual people
are capable of doing that we're not just
cursed
by whatever our nature is and whatever
we were born with
one of the contexts in which i've seen
this play out in in sort of the real
world
ironically is las vegas where i went and
followed some professional poker players
around and
spent some time trying to understand the
subculture of professional poker
which i think is interesting because it
exists in this environment of a casino
sort of sometimes on these floors above
the main floor of a casino where the
roulette and the blackjack's being
played below
and where the subculture really
encourages thinking ahead
i would say in a sense in the sense that
professional poker is played over the
course of many hands many games over a
tournament
and the players have to learn how not to
act on their impulses
and act rashly based on particular hands
or particular people or players that
they have vendettas against
and there's a whole set of norms and
language that reinforces
that form of thinking ahead terms like
grinding which is sort of like
being an apprentice in a renaissance
sculptor's studio this idea that you
grind away for years before you become
a successful professional poker player i
also in some more serious context
found how culture and norms
could have a big effect on thinking
ahead and one of those is in the
prescription of antibiotics which we all
know is
happening at such a high rate in very in
many ways
wrongly so more than half of
prescriptions given for coughs and colds
in the united states and the uk
are given incorrectly and at much higher
rates in the developing world we suspect
and we know that that's giving rise to
superbugs drug-resistant
bacteria that are spreading around the
world by 2050 we expect 10 million
people a year to die from these
superbugs
and it's a preventable problem right
because there's a moment in which
doctors prescribe
these medications where they could
choose not to right and they're doing
what's
good for the individual in the immediate
sense or what they believe is good for
the individual in the immediate sense
and neglecting what's good for the
long-term collective
seems like one of those conundrums
that's impossible to solve
but in fact there are a number of
hospitals and doctors offices
that have addressed this problem really
successfully and it's through culture
and setting new norms one example of
this is
primary practices primary care practices
that
put up posters in the exam rooms where
the exam
the poster would say basically we don't
prescribe antibiotics in this practice
unless they're really needed it sets up
a new expectation
on the part of the doctor and also on
the part of the patient who might be
begging for that antibiotic for their
kid who's been sick for a few days
and doesn't want to wait to see that
bacterial culture come back doesn't want
to wait
to see if the cold will go away because
it's a virus but it's
changing the norms another experiment
that had
a great deal of success in the uk was
sending letters to doctors telling them
how they perform relative to their peers
so
high-profile british leaders sent out
thousands of letters to doctors who were
the worst performing at
prescribing these antibiotics they found
that they
reduced in a six month period 80 000
inappropriate
prescriptions of antibiotics saving a
ton of money for the national health
care system as well
so the second reason i have some
optimism about our ability to think
ahead
is that the commons is not always a
tragedy
so this idea that when there's a shared
resource
like the ocean uh like a forest
and nobody owns it there's
a sense that that resource is going to
be destroyed over time it's a concept
that comes from neoclassical
economics and the idea is
no person has the incentive or
motivation to protect that resource
everyone will take what they can from it
because they're in a race with everyone
else to sort of use as much as they can
of that resource before it's destroyed
there's no sort of collective sense or
ability to preserve that resource for
the future
and a very classic example in fact um
the sort of seminal essay about
this idea of the tragedy of the commons
uh was written by garrett hardin in the
late 60s
though aristotle thought of it long
before um so
it's not a unique idea to garrett harden
but he gets a lot of credit and he used
fisheries as his example of what happens
to the commons
people over fish right fish are in the
ocean
everyone wants to get some fishermen
come and they take it eventually the
fish
the fishery collapses everyone's left
wondering wondering what happened
well i found examples of where this
specific tragedy of the commons has been
overcome
one of them in galveston texas where the
red snapper
commercial fishery has been brought back
from the brink of extermination
it was in 2004 2005 vastly overfished
uh destructively overfished and one of
the fishermen there who i spoke to
said he used to fish like a pirate and
go out under
the cloak of night in sort of dangerous
conditions
to get as much fish as he could during
what were known as annual derby days
this is a way that a lot of fisheries
have been
typically managed in the united states
um over
since sort of the 40s and what happened
was
the group of fishing businesses
fishermen in galveston
running the red snapper fishery got
together and they decided to form a
collective agreement
a collective way of managing this
fishery to bring it back
known as a cat share where the fishermen
and each fishing business becomes
like a long-term investor essentially
with one specified
share of the fishery as a whole and so
as the fishery grows your share of that
grows over time
and that sort of simple but also complex
way of organizing the fishery
has been really successful in bringing
it back and there are about 22
cat share managed fisheries in north
america that have been studied to have
similar results not all so dramatic is
this one
another example of the commons not being
so tragic
uh is uh a story that i found
and sort of tell in the book about
richland county
south carolina so this is mullen taylor
who used to be a county official and is
still a lawyer
down there in richland and richland
county and richland county is by the way
where colombia the capital
of south carolina is and about
roughly 15 years ago or so there was a
proposal to
to develop a very dangerous floodplain
in this county it was an area where they
wanted to put a billion dollar real
estate development with golf courses
with an
elderly home with all kinds of
businesses
and residences and even though there
were floodplain maps showing this was
sort of the regulatory floodway which is
where waters
rush really really quickly during a
storm event
there were heavy lobbying interests on
the part of these developers
they had a lot of political influence
and they were trying to push through
this development
and this is an example of where
political leadership and the law
can actually do a lot to help manage the
commons for the greater good for the
future
the zoning laws on the books in richland
county as well as
the legal precedent set by this battle
to protect grand central terminal that
played out in the 60s and 70s
that was used to basically protect this
area of land from development
which later has flooded and sort of
proven the point that it would have been
a reckless place to develop in the first
place
and i wanted to tell the story because
so often we hear and we see the other
side of the story which is to say
we see a wild land or or a region that's
been developed
in a wildfire zone that then goes up in
flames obviously california
has seen the devastating results of that
we see
the floodplain that has been
overdeveloped and then floods and
people's homes
are are destroyed and often people are
people's lives and we don't often see
the opposite side of that right we it's
very hard to tell the counterfactual
story and
i wanted to sort of excavate that and
try to understand
how how the leaders had managed to make
that happen and how the law sort of
functioned
to help protect the commons over the
long term
and so those lessons can be applied by
other communities
all right a third reason for optimism
about our ability to think ahead
is that we have history and we have
imagination
and these are two factors that i think
really can expand our ability to think
about the future
in ways that we haven't before and that
can allow us to meet our obligations
to think more about in fact future
generations
so it's very specific it's it's it's not
just
using history randomly using history i
found in
in the examples and in in the research i
did for the book
and i'll give you first an example of
where i think history can actually be
very limiting and how we think about the
future
so this is uh the olympic village that
was built for the 1972
olympics in munich and for those who
don't know
this was an example of a group of people
who really thought they were thinking
ahead who believed they were doing what
was right in terms of planning for
future disaster so
the organizers of the munich olympics in
1972
hired a police psychologist this is a
job i didn't know existed until i
researched his book
um this was a guy named georg zieber who
had been sort of a double agent he would
infiltrate student groups student
protest groups
in in munich and he would also work for
the police and so then he would inform
the other
that the police was going to be at the
protest and that the
the protesters that the police were
going to be there i'm sorry the other
way around
that the protest was happening and um
and he thought that what he was doing
was avoiding
conflagrations between these two groups
by letting everyone know that they're
going to be there so then they just
expected it
um so anyway they hired this guy george
zieber
to paint scenarios of what could go
wrong at the munich olympics
and he came up with 26 scenarios
including some very mundane scenarios
like
someone gets pushed into a swimming pool
but one of the scenarios he came up with
which was known as situation 21
was uh the scenario that actually
happened which was
uh that terrorist group palestinian
terrorist group
climbed the fence at the olympic village
just before dawn one day
took hostage israeli athletes and
of course what ultimately happened is
there was a massacre of athletes
and also of the terrorists now
so you would think that the olympic
organizers being given these scenarios
might have done something to plan for
them
but in fact what happened was they heard
the scenarios and they said that sounds
very nice but
we actually don't want any of those
things to happen and we're not really
interested in
planning for them so they sort of
sanitized the scenario that they'd been
presented with
and there were reasons for that one of
which was that this was the first time
the olympics had been held in germany
since 1936 when hitler had presided over
them
so there was a sense that they wanted to
rebrand the olympic games in germany so
they were
they had this idea that uh this should
be the cheerful games they actually
called them
dehydran spila which i think is the
carefree or cheerful games
and they had a mascot and doxy
and um they really didn't want to have
it seem militaristic so they didn't want
to put armed guards on the perimeter of
the olympic village which was what
zebra had suggested that they do and so
they were kind of trapped by history
i think in some in my estimation uh
it their recent history their recent
memory prevented them from actually
planning for a realistic future scenario
and even the most basic ways just taking
basic precautions
and i want to contrast that with a use
of history that i think
actually can be helpful in in thinking
ahead which
um is from japan uh this is yanosuke
hirai
who's the the arrow is over and um i was
in fukushima on the sixth anniversary
of the nuclear disaster there and i
learned about hirai when i was there
because
he was the engineer who was behind the
onagawa nuclear power station which was
closer to the epicenter of the
earthquake the
earthquake of 2011 that destroyed the
fukushima
nuclear power plant led to the meltdown
and
onagawa even though it was closer to the
epicenter
had been safe it was a place of refuge
for people in the city
during the disaster and i wanted to
understand
so why was onagawa safe when fukushima
you know was not and and it was really
this engineer's name who came up
uh several times because he had insisted
that that nuclear power station be built
further back from the sea with a higher
elevation and with a higher seawall
and the reason that he insisted on that
he didn't live to see this earthquake by
the way
but the reason he insisted on it was
because he had this memory he had this
knowledge i should say
of his hometown shrine which had had a
plaque uh honoring
the sort of memory of a tsunami from the
year 869
the shogun earthquake and uh he carried
that knowledge that a tsunami could have
that kind of destructive effect and it
led to how he
thought about this and planned for this
uh piece of infrastructure this nuclear
power plant in a way
that was uh had more greater foresight
than
um than the tepco the the nuclear power
company that ran fukushima and so i
think part of the lesson here
is that we need longer historical memory
so often we're only thinking back and
that's not just thinking it's also the
models we use to predict future risk so
tepco the tokyo electric power company
which was behind the fukushima
owned fukushima daiichi that nuclear
power station
they were using computer models to model
risks
like tsunami like an earthquake
to their power station but they were
their data only went back something
like a couple of decades and the one in
a thousand year event of an earthquake
like the one that happened in 2011
could have been put into their models
but they didn't look far enough back
the other thing i'll say is that we also
need to use multiple historical
analogies often to plan for the future
and think about the future
and this proved to be one of the the key
factors in the cuban missile crisis that
allowed
uh kennedy and sort of the american side
to manage all the scenarios that they
were thinking about with khrushchev when
krushev
had the missiles in cuba that could have
led to
you know mutually assured destruction
and and that also
i think that idea of multiple histories
um is also limited
even though it's important uh that often
what we're experiencing is unprecedented
change and particularly with climate
change
we see scenarios that have never played
out
in recent experience or historical
experience of humans sort of in the
written record
and so we need ways to extend our
imagination well beyond
even what uh what's in our history books
and for that uh there are a number of
tools that can be used including
art including role play games
including virtual reality that will
allow us to inhabit scenarios fiction
allow us to to be able to create and and
and believe
in possibilities both negative and
positive in the future
that we have yet to imagine and so
that's one of the reasons i believe that
we're capable of a lot more long-term
thinking than we do
because we have that capacity for
imagination we just don't always apply
it to thinking about the future
all right and the fourth reason fourth
and final reason i'll share
for my optimism about our ability to
think ahead is that we are heirloom
keepers
so i sort of at the beginning of my
process of writing the book
and part of the inspiration for writing
the book
was getting an heirloom from my
great-grandfather i
got it through my grandmother i never
met my great-grandfather but he was a
music and art critic in south india
in the early 20th century and he was the
only person i'd known in my family who
was a writer
so i really kind of connected with that
there were
a bunch of engineers a bunch of doctors
a bunch of business people
but there were no sort of creative
writers that i'd known and sort of in my
family and
this instrument which is called a
dilruba and has more than 20 strings
had been given to him as a gift he was
often given gifts by
musicians and artists who he wrote about
which now i think would be bad
journalistic
practice but um the standards of the
time so
um so i when i got this instrument uh
it was really moving to me in many ways
uh in part because it was this
connection to this member of my family
who i actually
felt some sort of was some sort of
kindred spirit and also
because it really made me feel like i
had some sort of
new role i really felt like the power of
being a descendant
and then immediately it raised for me
the question of
what kind of ancestor i was going to be
who i was going to pass
this instrument onto who i was going to
share it with
and i know many of you in your families
you probably have
objects pieces of jewelry or furniture
or things that have been passed down to
you that perhaps you think about passing
down to others and that practice
that idea of having something precious
that you shepherd through time
is in fact a very human experience it's
something that we all
can relate to i think even if we haven't
had a direct immediate experience
of it and i don't believe that that's
just something that happens
in our families that it just has to stay
as a sort of individual family
experience i think it's also something
that we can do collectively that we can
do
in a way that fosters heirlooms that
belong to our communities
and in fact to humanity and one of the
examples of this that we have
of course in this country are our
national parks this is yosemite of
course since we're
it's close to here close to home and
the national park system is in fact i
think a way of institutionally
creating and shepherding shared
heirlooms we protect these landscapes we
have
laws we have resources financial
resources that sustain them over time
but also importantly they're not just
sort of time capsules buried for some
future generation
each generation uses them each
generation gets to experience them
and even adapt them if they want and
that's what i think makes an heirloom
very different
than something that just gets buried and
unearthed by some future society
it's something that belongs to each
generation in part and that gets
shepherded
and i found other examples of such
heirlooms as well
including a fishery in mexico that i
wrote about in the book
where lobster fishermen across eight
different communities have banded
together to treat the fishery like a
shared heirloom
that they're managing collectively for
their descendants
and i found that incredibly inspiring
now also as i look at the youth climate
movements
i feel that greta thundberg and the
climate strikers
the sunrise movement the young people
who are out in the streets
who were on television telling us my
generation and generations older to do
something about the climate crisis
are in fact in a way sort of asking us
to be better heirloom
asking us to be better ancestors and
asking us to
treat the planet like an heirloom asking
us to treat our atmosphere
like a shared heirloom our oceans like a
shared heirloom
and i found that find that to be very
powerful because it involves
a conversation across generations
between young and old
and it's very human and in within our
capacity to do
so do i think that we will do better
than the people of pompeii
do i think that we will save our
civilizations
save all of our resources for the future
i don't actually know
the answer to that question but i do
know that we can do better
and that is the basis for my optimism
and why i believe that long-term
thinking is not just some special
precious trait of a few but something
that we are deeply capable of
something we can hone with the right
tools and knowledge we just haven't been
aware
of all of the ways in which we can
actually enhance our ability to think
ahead and
since zander pointed out it's the
beginning of the year and
it's also the beginning of the decade
i want to close with a few practical
tools
because practical tools were promised
for your lives
so things you can can do at home
that are safe to do at home i think i
think you're safe to do them
first is mining what you measure and
here i'll just lean on herodotus the
ancient greek historian so he wrote
about
um this wise person who
with the athenian statesman solin who
after he passed a bunch of reforms in
athens he banned the practice of
enslaving people when they had debts
good things he got he got plebians the
right to vote
and then he sort of left and went on
this trip and he went to sardis
in in modern day turkey and he met this
king concretus
and as herodotus tells it krisis the
king takes him
takes solon on this tour of
um his palace and all of his riches and
on the after the tour he asked solon
because someone's considered this wise
man he asked him
well who's the happiest man alive who's
the happiest man on earth
and it's like leading the witness and
and solon
says well no it's this guy telus
actually and he's dead
and um and telus is this athenian
general
and he's the happiest man because he
died heroically in battle and he's
survived by all of these children and
grandchildren he's made such an impact
and crisis was not happy with that
answer and
uh and so solon sort of shot shoots back
with well you know your life
is an average lifespan is more than 26
000 days and on this day
you have this wealth amassed here but
that doesn't tell me anything about
what your life is going to be in some
and in fact then crisis goes on to lose
his son
lose his kingdom lose his riches and so
i say this because we are in a culture
where we measure ourselves by the
immediate constantly
by the number of steps we take by the
quarter
target we hit by the number of emails
we've answered this
year or week or day or hour
and those are those are measures that
are often ephemeral
they're not meaningful for what we want
to accomplish so
i really encourage thinking about
milestones thinking about what you
measure
in your life as having a link to what
you actually want to be remembered for
what you want to accomplish and those
measures i think are the more meaningful
ones for us and also the ones that
ultimately become more satisfying
because you're not just like
rolling the ball up the hill and then
boulder up the hill and then having to
start over again the next day with more
to measure
the second piece of advice is to
reinforce the norm of thinking ahead
which you're all doing by being here
among fellow long-term thinkers but uh
it's really the idea of being like
professional poker players which is to
say
surround yourself with other people who
can provide that cultural reinforcement
that norm
that thinking ahead and valuing the
future matters
because this is harder to do in
isolation because of some of those
aspects of our nature
that are still there from our
hunter-gatherer days
and the final piece of advice is to
commit to a shared heirloom
so this can be something small in your
community a forest
a library uh a aquifer
something that is worth protecting for
the future so just like everything from
your parents basement
is not a family heirloom everything in
our society cannot be a shared heirloom
but there are certain resources right
that we've inherited
that we know are going to be valued by
humans in the future even if we can't
imagine
exactly what those humans are going to
be like
and some of what we need to pass along
some of those shared heirlooms are in
fact
knowledge and i thank you all for
listening to some of mine and i look
forward to hearing some of yours
thank you um and we did a slightly
shorter talk tonight to allow for a
little bit more
discussion and i also want to say um
bina was nice enough to
sign some of her books out in the lobby
if you want to grab a signed copy
they are there um and
i want to dive a little bit into at
first into this
tragedy of the commons i think the i
think you were right to start the book
with it because i mean
fundamentally the story around long now
and long-term thinking
is is how humanity can be a good
ancestor and take a step back
and start thinking about these the
things that uh
that are that hunter gather may not be
able to um
with limited resources and i think you
touched on it with the
cameroonian toddlers too is it's
in some level uh long-term thinking is a
luxury
um and you have to have a certain level
of comfort in your life
to do it um but it doesn't necessarily
mean
people have more resources have to do it
and so i just want to
talk a little bit more about resource
level and comfort level and and
where it fits in yeah scarcity i'm
scarcity definitely has an impact on our
ability to think ahead and
uh you know scarcity can be
of resources right so if you're if you
need a pair of shoes
and you have 20 to buy a pair of shoes
and you are racing between you know
picking up your kids from daycare and
your second job of the day
and you're just going to get a pair of
shoes you're not going to be thinking
about whether those shoes are going to
last
for 50 years or or 10 years or even like
are they going to make it through the
year you're going to buy whatever pair
of shoes
uh you're able to get and and that is
three can be extrapolated
you know it's um it's very common for
people of low income particularly in the
u.s right to play the lottery
or to fall prey to pawn brokers
and that's true in the developing world
too so if you have less
it can often ironically it's harder to
build the capacity
to get yourself out of that cycle
because it seems like
what you should do is try to to actually
get yourself out of the hole
you need something much bigger so
instead of putting that away for savings
you might actually say okay
i think it's just worth it to buy the
scratch ticket and that's actually been
used there are ways to collectively use
that so i think we need to kind of rely
on our collective institutions on our
shared resources and our communities to
help us with that
um so there's actually been schemes
designed including in michigan through
this credit union league
to link uh lottery playing the lottery
to savings
so that uh when people uh
go to save in these particular kind of
savings accounts which are called price
link savings accounts
they're also getting some of their
interest gets put into a pool that's a
lottery that's run on a monthly basis
and so they have the prospect of sort of
winning big
jackpots even if most people don't but
they're not gambling away their money
they're actually saving in the process
and that's
proven wildly successful they try this
right after the financial crisis and
they thought this might not work because
people don't have a lot of spare money
and they encourage a lot of low-income
people to save that way so i think
this there are ways that we can kind of
come together and help people who are in
scarcity
uh to do better at long-term thinking
but it's also not
i think the cameroonian toddler
experiment is important because
it's one of several examples that i've
documented where
it's it's not always the case that
what you have materially is going to
determine how you make decisions right
there's going to be
there are exceptions to every rule and
there are ways in which culture and
environment can actually overpower
that basic sort of necessity right and i
assume that cameroonian teenagers had
lived in so much scarcity that they were
more willing to
forgo wait a little bit longer the
toddlers
the toddlers yeah i mean the researcher
bettina lamb who's the german uh
researcher who led this experiment she
she surmised of course it's like these
it's very hard to say like what are the
factors
how exactly was the culture doing this
but that
they were kind of raised to be more
disciplined in general
and so there was a sense of just less
indulgence of of the babies and and the
toddlers that
might have contributed to that right
yeah
and um
one of the topics that you brought up uh
in the book that i was really intrigued
by is this idea of um
of prospective hindsight and i mean a
lot of what you talk about is
in some way as kind of a gamification of
long-term thinking and obviously with
the poker that's
that's very much the case but there are
these um ideas of if-thens and looking
back from the future scenarios that i
think are really really helpful i don't
know if you could talk about that yeah
that's a really and that's good that's
more practical advice for people's lives
and since we build this this way to give
people the tips
uh but so prospective hindsight is
so when you usually or when i typically
think about
the future i'll i'll say okay i really
want this
meeting or this and okay right now we're
i'm the editorial page editor of the
boston globe and we're doing our
endorsements
of presidential candidates so we've been
interviewing the presidential candidates
and we're going to come out with it
endorsement soon and so i'm thinking oh
i really want this to go well
like i want people to read it i want the
endorsement to be really really well i
want to look like this on the page and
this online and i'm thinking i'm
fixating on all these things
that i want to go well in the future and
i should probably use prospective
hindsight so
perspective hindsight is a technique
that allows you to sort of get past
thinking about all the factors that you
can't control in the present
and focusing you and distilling sort of
what are the factors
what are the decisions you have that
affect future scenarios so what you
would do is you imagine an
outcome as if it's already happened and
so you could do this with like a dinner
party for example or i could do it with
the endorsement page on the you know in
the globe
and say okay imagine it's gone really
really well like you just had the best
dinner party and then walk back and ask
yourself
why it happened and how it happened and
make a list of those reasons uh why was
it so great well the conversation was
really good
people really hit it up like there was a
lot of interesting people there
the food was delicious it's probably not
factors like
you know maybe the weather made it made
a little bit of a difference but it's
probably not factors like that
it probably doesn't matter whether you
served dessert
right away or if you waited right so all
these sort of things that we can fixate
on about the future
get kind of stripped away when you ask
the how and the why
um and that's just a technique you can
use
you can also imagine a scenario going
very very wrong and then walk yourself
back from that
and this debra mitchell who was a
wharton professor came up with this term
prospective hindsight for this and she
actually thought it would have worked
really well
to avoid the chernobyl disaster if if
this technique had been used but in fact
in our lives we can use something like
this
and then you asked about if then tactics
as well yeah well i think i mean that
came up i think with the the poker
players and i think it was
uh especially in a in a world where
what seems like a world where there's so
they have so little control
right um using and if then and a lot of
it is about impulse control and that was
a very powerful and impulse control yeah
so
matt matrows who's a professional poker
player has made more than two million
make playing poker he's won the world
series of poker uh
told me about how he goes about planning
for
a poker tournament at poker game and so
he sets out he thinks about scenarios he
might
face in the moment that would cause him
to make sort of rash decisions
like he's next to a player who's got a
lot of bravado
who he's played against in the past and
he's going to be tempted to just kind of
whatever just lay it all out there and
do something that doesn't make sense
he's also going to think about card
combinations so he's very mathematical
the way he plays
and he'll think about scenarios he could
face at the poker table and what he
would do
under each of them based on what the
odds will be so he actually does some
forecasting like that and basically
that is a version of a technique that's
been studied by peter goldwitzer who's a
nyu professor who's documented this
in sort of many many dozens of settings
uh called if-then tactics and this works
very well for new year's resolutions by
the way
so if you if you have a new year's
resolution and you're just telling
yourself you know i'm going to go to the
gym
five days a week or three days a week we
all know how that usually turns
out you something happens right you end
up there for me it's like okay it's
really cold since i live in boston it's
really cold this morning i want to go to
the gym but i just
i just like don't i just want another
hour of sleep and let it warm up a
little bit
and then i then i'll just go to work and
uh so
if you're doing an if then tactic what
you would do is you would say
if i'm okay i'm gonna make the
resolution gym three days a week
if it's really cold in the morning then
i will and then i state some sort of
positive thing i will do
that will get me to actually do this
thing so if it's a really cold morning
i will turn up like the hip-hop really
loud
at six a.m and that'll get me out of bed
and then i'll
then i'll go to the gym uh so it's sort
of
anticipating all the hurdles that might
get in the way of your long-term goal
uh and thinking of those short-term
hurdles and then stating affirmatively
what you'll do to avoid them and this by
the way was also has also been shown to
you
work in classrooms where teachers have
implicit bias when disciplining
school children so there's this pattern
in which
black and brown students are sent to the
principal's office more often in
classrooms across the country
and that has disproportionate impact on
their outcomes in life because
if you go to this it's sort of this out
of school you go to this
principal's office you're more likely to
be suspended you're more likely to be
suspending more likely ended up in the
prison system
so this whole chain of events and it
starts with the teacher and the student
in the classroom
and teachers that i interviewed who'd
use these techniques
had found a way to actually change some
of the outcomes in their schools
and their classrooms and what they would
do is say okay i know that there's
certain students that just
irritate me or i know if i haven't eaten
enough i'm going to end up disciplining
my students
too harshly so if a student acts up in
class
then i'm going to first drop my pencil
and count to three
before i decide what to do with the
student and it's basically a way of
planning ahead for a situation that's
prone to an impulsive reaction
and it has been shown to have some at
least some
some preliminary positive results in
preventing people from acting on their
implicit bias
right so with the poker player it was to
not make an emotional play
if they if they're prepared for every
card combination and the teacher's case
not make an emotional play when angry
with the student
right right yeah an emote sort of an
emotional play and one that's just based
on that immediate
impulse instead of maybe what a lot of
these teachers right they don't want to
actually be doing this
they just find themselves in the moment
making those decisions but if they
really think about what's good for the
long-term
goals of their students or the classroom
it's not necessarily sending the kids to
the principal's office
right yeah when i'm about to send an
email that i think is going to make
someone angry i just decide i wait till
the next day and then i re-read it
yeah that's my pencil drop
and then i usually end up never sending
it giving him a call so yeah
um can you say a little bit more about
the motivations that kind of
worked in this catch share thing i know
that um i think we've had many talks
here about the tragedy
of um where our fisheries are
and um i was really i never heard about
these catch share
um plans and so i i um i think that was
in a way it was it's kind of this global
story um
that is playing out in a few fisheries
and hopefully
more of them so i want to make it more
famous yeah yeah and at least but what
is it
what was the motivation in north america
now have have twenty two
last years yeah but what was the motive
how does that motivation work with catch
share for the fishermen themselves
so uh sometimes it takes a crisis in
this particular fishery and galveston
that i talked about the red snapper
fishery
the fishery really was on the brink of
collapse so
fishermen were finding that they were
going out longer and longer days and
more and more dangerous conditions they
were leaving
weddings so one of these fishermen buddy
gindenite that i interviewed he was he
would leave family events like reunions
or weddings
just so he could steal out in the night
and be the first one kind of out on the
reefs to get
these fish like what was left of the
fish and
then they were all bringing them back on
these on the same days because the
the fishery was organized by these derby
days and then there would just be a glut
in the market
and the prices were really low plus a
lot of
chefs were not putting the fish putting
red snapper on their menus because
they couldn't there wasn't a dependable
catch anymore it was basically dwindling
and when it was there it was just like
all there and then when it wasn't it
wasn't available
so i think they really saw the writing
on the wall in terms of the fishery
collapsing
and they were approached by an
environmental organization
edf that sort of was trying to
pioneer different ways of managing
fisheries and they came together
uh with the regional there's like sort
of regional councils that govern
fisheries in the u.s and
basically decided that they should try
this way of doing things
now there's the big debate about it is
it sort of grandfathers in
the fishing businesses that are already
there so it's not easy for new people to
come in because the shares are all
allocated based on who's been
historically fishing
and the the reason that they are
interested in the long i mean obviously
they're interested in the long-term
future of the fishery because they want
to keep fishing but
the way the share system works at least
as i understood it is that by owning a
share
not fishing the fishery can be as
valuable as fishing the fishery yes so
reducing the pressure on the fishery
allows the stocks to replenish
and bounce back over time and that means
your share can be bigger
over time you can also you can also
lease out your share
part of your catch for someone else to
catch that year if you want to fish less
that year
it provides a way of planning sort of
over time and then also
which is really important a lot of
fishing communities and i've spent time
in
maybe a dozen fishing communities around
the world just over the years
between being a reporter and just having
an interest in in fisheries
and often it is a matter of sort of
heritage or uh it's a matter of culture
as much as it is
of business where people really do want
to pass this on to their kids and
grandkids they really do want the
fishery to be like an heirloom even if
they wouldn't use that term
and uh they want to see some longevity
of that as a cultural practice as part
of the identity of a place and
there just haven't been ways to really
do that right you are racing everyone
else to fish
and if you don't you're kind of left out
so i think the fact that there were
these collective agreements
allowed people to sort of have the
pressure off and they can also fish
whenever they want until they meet their
their share quota so
they don't have to go out during family
weddings or in bad weather
gotcha yeah and that i mean so yeah so
fundamentally their shares just become
more valuable the more valuable the
fishery is
yeah and so they're they're incentivized
to not degrade the fishery as a whole
exactly yeah and the more the fishery
grows the more their share grows
as well yeah it seems like it would be a
really great practice for forestry
yeah as well some of these other shared
resources
and i mean you worked uh in the obama
administration
often trying to commit convince people
that climate change
uh kind of the dangers of climate change
and how to mitigate climate change and
how much did that play a role in the
beginning of this book
and kind of what you learned about human
nature yeah a big role
so you know a lot of writing projects
are born out of frustration
and this this was no exception um
so when you're angry or frustrated with
something in the world
it helps to be able to write so i yes i
worked in the obama white house and i
my role was working with communities and
companies
sharing climate science climate data and
the idea was
the data and the science would be used
by these groups to plan ahead for future
wildfires future droughts
uh future floods and
i had varying success with that so you
sit down across
from an executive who tells you this all
sounds really nice like this all sounds
really useful
um i'm glad to have this information
about my supply chain
but you know my shareholders are all
really thinking about the quarter
i'm evaluated based on my quarterly and
annual performance
um and i just this is this 10-year
horizon is not really
the horizon which i make decisions you
know they don't say it in those many
words unless they're sort of
talking to you privately but that's the
kind of impression you get and
um i really wanted to understand i mean
i think
there was it was easy to sort of
conveniently
excuse that behavior as just being a
byproduct of human nature to say
well we're just not capable of thinking
ahead and these executives are an
example that they're just
they don't think ahead and i think that
that's actually
um i i just i think that's a neglect of
our obligations and i also think
based on the research i did for the book
you know
the book started as a book about
short-term thing i was going to call it
like there's no tomorrow
so but uh but as i kept researching
these examples
and probing more deeply
i found that there was just so much more
possibility that there
that this was not some curse of human
nature that there were actually choices
we were making and that we
could make different choices are we
going to i don't know but
the fact that we can i think is really
meaningful and i think it needs to be
spread because
uh you know the executive who then hears
about paul pullman who actually was
managing beyond the quarter who is the
ceo of unilever until recently and
was not just his bonus was being um
tied to how much he was reducing the
greenhouse gas emissions of the company
on the whole
not just based on his profits on the
quarter right
so the more models and examples there
are i think the more we can do for sure
and i think that yeah
the and he he made bonuses in the tens
of millions of dollars based on reducing
greenhouse gases
so i don't think it's always that
lucrative to do do the right thing but
in that case right it was um and
just before we get to some of the
questions that i know are are coming
down
um and um i'm gonna give stewart brown
the first
question um but um the the
the story about the real estate
developer that ended up not developing
the thing can you say a little bit more
about how that actually what were the
mechanics of that working how did they
how did they convince people
and the i mean there was tons and tons
of pressure from every angle both the
economics of the town that wanted to be
revived as well as the developers who
obviously want to make money from the
development itself
how did they actually win that argument
yeah it took a couple there was a county
councilwoman
named kit smith along with the lawyer
whose image i showed mullen taylor who
these two women who were really
uh just standing very strong to try to
get more information about the risks to
the floodplain
while they were trying to push the
development through and ultimately as
they
generated and collected more data and
showed how dangerous this would be
they started to get some interesting
allies including a group of hunters
sort of land landowners in the area who
didn't want to see the development for
other reasons because they didn't want
their hunting grounds to be sort of
contaminated by this
um by the golf course and the and the
sort of development the commercial
development
uh but then they also had to fight a
really
acrimonious legal battle so the
developer sued the county
and this happens in a lot of places and
this is sort of the fear of these
lawsuits
also is almost more powerful than
the actual damage that's done by them so
a lot of communities will just think
that they have to do what developers
want and if they don't let developers do
what they want to the land that they own
in this case the developer already own
the land that they'll be sued and that
that will just
you know drain or bankrupt the city
coffers or the county coffers
and so a lot of municipalities kind of
go forth green lighting these
developments that they know might be
reckless
and so what the what the legal battle
the
south carolina supreme court ended up
deciding uh
was that the county had the right to
prevent this development
and they relied on this um this ruling
from the case that had uh the
that had new york city had won
in the 1970s this u.s supreme court case
uh and it happened after penn station
was sort of turned into the modern day
penn station which is this hideous
monstrosity
um and they wanted to do the same
a developer wanted to do something
similar build a high-rise above grand
central terminal which is this beautiful
bozart piece of architecture in new york
and marble edifice and
the idea that this
the character of this landmark of grand
central terminal would be
permanently destroyed by the development
was the basis by which the city
rejected the development and that went
all the way to the u.s supreme court and
a ruling
there was then used to argue that this
community in south carolina
could protect this piece of land based
on
posterity based on what was good for
basically the future
collective of the community and so i
think it was important to tell that
story because it's both the political
leadership of these two women
and the fact how they handled um how
they handled the development which was
in part sort of like the the putting the
brakes on the impulsive decision was
like dropping the pencil they
essentially put a pause on the whole
process to get more information about
the risk
and then what they also did was use this
powerful legal precedent and it just
sort of speaks to the importance
of our institutions um which of course
we're in a sort of dark time
for the state of our institutions in
this country but um it's just a reminder
of how much they matter
right two strong women that's the answer
yes
was there another reason to tell the
story um
so stuart brand um aston i think you
touched on it with the the story of
japan a little bit but i
i love these anecdotes and i think
they're important is um
these stories of when our ancestors were
good ancestors
um and posthumously this this japanese
kind of governor was able to um avert a
really bad situation but did you come
across any other situations where our
ancestors were great ancestors and they
kind of knew
they were being great ancestors that's a
great question
i they're you know i don't know if they
ever know for sure that they're being
great ancestors which i think is another
thing for us to keep in mind
and this principle of the heirloom for
me
resonated because i think as we look
further even though our predictive power
is getting better it's not perfect
and as you look across generations with
the exception of some issues like
climate change where our
our looking to the future we're actually
more accurate in the models sometimes
looking further out than we are like
next week or
two week two years from now um
that there because we don't know what's
going to happen generation after
generation we don't know
you know how much gene editing is going
to be used to alter species we don't
know
what society is going to look like five
generations from now
in some respects that heirloom is sort
of more
a source a way of dealing with future
generations that acknowledges
um or that has humility embedded into it
because
all we're saying is we're going to
shepherd something to the next
generation we're going to protect
something that's valuable to us
for the next generation we're going to
create something that's valuable for the
next generation
and rely on them and give them the
responsibility to shepherd it onward and
i would say that one example of that
that
i think is interesting from the book are
these tsunami markers
from from japan also um
which is not to say that only japanese
people can do this um but
uh that there were these markers in two
particular
communities that proved successful
warnings for the
2011 tsunami and there are a bunch of
other markers by the way across japan
that did not have this success but one
of them was in murahama
where there was this hill which was the
high point where people had fled
during the 869 shogun earthquake and
tsunami that i mentioned
and people went to this high point
thinking if there's a tsunami coming
they're going to be safe and what
happened was two waves crashed
on that hill and so it was actually the
least safe place to be
and they had a marker that
they put there saying do not flee to
this hill
helpful helpful ancestral message
and and that in fact was heated
in the 2011 tsunamis and two waves again
crashed over the hill
and i and that and the other was anna
yoshi which was a warning that said do
not build below this point
like very specific in both cases the
messages were very specific
it's like nothing vague about this and
so some of the other markers were a lot
vague they were like just
vague memorials like we're very sorry
about the people who died here in the
tsunami which is great but not the same
as
like don't build below the slide
and the aniyoshi the community did not
do that and that was also another place
that was
relatively better off during the 2011
tsunamis
right yeah i guess obviously it's it's
easier to know
where not to run than where not to build
for 1200 years to say
yeah the pressures are much much greater
to build
for the same give them more props yeah
that's right
but that they did tell the story for
1200 years and save the lives
yeah and i think that's the other
component that makes it more like an
heirloom is that it wasn't just the
marker and then the marker was forgotten
that they were actually teaching school
children
in these communities and so the
knowledge was being passed down like an
heirloom it wasn't just a marker in the
landscape it was something
that was more sort of stewarded
shepherded across generations
and um kevin kelly asks besides the the
marshmallow test are there
other lessons for long-term thinking for
five-year-olds
or people that act like five-year-olds
or people who act like five-year-olds
um
well i do think this idea of uh
of creating buffers to our impulses is
important
and that also by the way worked for the
the it was another tactic that worked
for the doctors prescribing antibiotics
which was to create a little pop-up in
the electronic health record when
they're about to prescribe the
antibiotic that says
what's the basically what's your reason
for for prescribing this antibiotic to
this patient it's just a simple
question like and if you don't want to
answer it you have to check no
justification given and then that goes
in the permanent record
so could you use that for a
five-year-old uh
i think you know people do you i mean
actually i think in some ways people
parents i'm not a parent but i observe
parents using some of these tactics
maybe better than than the
rest of us because they're trying to get
their kids right to think beyond their
impulses and then we sort of forget
that we are as adults also very governed
by it
by our impulses uh and that our
technological tools reinforce that often
uh they don't have to i think there are
ways that we could use our technology
um to actually help us with long-term
thinking how many times we look at our
phones
a day yeah and and then yeah and i think
the way the engineer right the the
engineering around
facebook likes and tweets right like
it's it's made to reinforce the
availability bias which is basically
right like or
it does reinforce the availability of us
what we see is what we think is the most
important so we're constantly seeking
that um that same reinforcement that
same
sort of sense of satisfaction in the mor
in the moment and we think that that's
actually what's important when
perhaps what's really important is not
that not what's getting retweeted but
you know the erosion of the federal
court system
um or democracy itself yeah
um and can you think of some beloved
traditional objects
from bob copic um that we should not
preserve are there how do we how do we
actually you know as you pointed out we
can't preserve everything
and we have to make some decisions um
some are probably better for society
than others how do we how do we make
those decisions do you think
it's a great question i think
i think looking at what we what has been
valued over time
is a good way to measure that i think
what's measur
what's valuable in the moment right like
my phone is extremely valuable to me in
the moment i need it constantly
especially as a journalist
but has it been important to me since i
was a child
was it is it an object that was
important to my parents
no i mean it's not an object i need to
sacredly pass on to the future and i
think collectively
we could look at that as well what are
the what are the resources that have had
longevity you know
humans have always cared about art and
have always
you know music is important to humans
clean
air to breathe is important to clean
water right these are sort of
there are natural affinities between
humans and some of these
cultural resources sure there are lots
of pieces of
art do we need to protect all of them
maybe not for five generations but i
think
uh each generation will figure out
distill of what it's inherited what's
still valuable to that generation and
that i think is what makes it an
heirloom i can't think of yeah i mean i
want to think i want to have like
something specific that i want to throw
out
that's what i want to have the answer to
that question does anyone else have one
yeah which one confederate statues
that's a
that's a pretty good one all of our
amendments yeah i think it's
well i think on the i mean on the same
front i think
uh igor asks you know are there things
that are is there long forms of
long-term thinking that are actually
detrimental and i think
you know obviously like if you live
every day as though
um you're gonna you have to save
everything and
and never live for the moment you're
you're
you're depriving yourself and i think at
the end of your life you will have
wished you lived in the moment more than
if you hadn't
of course but if you don't save for your
retirement if you don't work enough to
pay for rent and food you have so
there's some balance here
yeah um and are there examples where
you've seen people go too far or
um how how do we think we should find
that balance
well i mean i think there are examples
of companies for example
that just never make real like it's one
thing to not have short-term results
it's another thing to be like
well 20 years from now for you you know
and never have it
never have it yield results never have
an invention that comes out or
or a profit that gets turned
um but i mean i i think this is the kind
of like
i don't love the idea i don't think that
living in the moment is incompatible
with being a long-term thinker so
i think you can live in the moment and
enjoy the present moment
but it's also a way of understanding
that you exist in time right that and
that this this moment is transforming
and that
we're constantly constantly in change i
think the difference
the the sort of lousy place that i find
we're in a lot in our
culture right now is in constant
anticipation of the immediate next
moment
which i think is very different than
being sort of mindful
present enjoying seizing the day i think
it's more like this anticipation of what
you're about to get or what about
what's about to happen and that i think
is the place where
we are anxious and where
we are neither in present or future um
but yes i mean all long-term thinking
is not always going to be positive right
there are examples i think
shall like some of the big oil companies
right that have done really well at
long-term thinking have they always
done that to the benefit of society no i
mean some of their long-term thinking
has actually been maybe not detrimental
to society um
so i don't talk about long-term thinking
like it's an inherent
good per se i think we need a lot more
of it because our culture's way out of
whack today
yeah something we're struggling with a
lot is what are you know long-term
thinking is not inherently good there
are people who use long-term thinking
for horrible things um and so
um how do you place values that are
autocratic regimes for example
the assyrians were right a long time
right
um but yeah um and i think we have
we actually have a lot of questions here
about both kind of the scale and the
speed at which
we need these kind of transformations in
society and and i know that you can't be
responsible for
all of this um but uh that the scale and
the speed obviously
or for things like climate change um
feel very
pressing yeah um and have you
what's your thought on on how to scale
some of these ideas
yeah so i think well
i think there's two kind of components
to that question about climate change
because i think some people
say well don't we just need to
don't we just need to act dramatically
and quickly on climate change like isn't
long-term thinking
or like is it any more long-term
thinking there's just so much danger
around us australia is burning
uh for example the arctic is melting
and i think that that is true that we
need dramatic
immediate response in terms of cutting
our emissions but this is also a
multi-generational problem so that we're
not going to
a singular response to do anything right
now is not going to solve the problem
and i actually worry
like there are some short-term responses
to climate change
including geoengineering which we may
need as one of the tools in the arsenal
of tools to address this crisis but
that if done rashly and quickly without
thinking about the consequences without
understanding what those consequences
could be
could be really dangerous could actually
be counterproductive
over the long run so i i think that we
do need long-term thinking
as an approach because we're going to
have to deal with this problem over time
there's not a quick fix to climate
change
and then i think there's this this
challenge of the scaling up which is
what you're saying basically that
the climate crisis is happening now can
we teach everyone to be long-term
thinkers
in time to address what we need to
address and
and the answer is somewhat similar
because i think long-term thinking is
not the only way to get action on
climate change i think there is this
immediate harm that people are
experiencing that's gonna
is bringing a lot of people into the
fight or into the
conversation about climate change is
making them make it a priority when they
vote
but that they still need to be able to
imagine so we saw
anyone who watched the presidential
primary debate democratic debate last
night would have seen that climate
change
even though the candidates brought it up
the moderators really didn't want to
talk about it and didn't want to
stay on it and it's it's a hard thing to
sort of keep in the news cycle right
it's
it's it's um
because it is still a problem of the
future for too many people
and i think that means that we need to
be able to bring it into our
imaginations
more when we go to the voting booth if
you
put your near-term stock portfolio which
is doing really well
in this economy under trump before
the future of your children and
grandchildren that's a failure of
imagination it means you're not able to
think
long-term enough the immediate outcome
is how you vote and how you vote is
going to affect our immediate response
to climate change in this country so i
think it's connected
um i don't think that we can give up on
making people better long-term thinkers
and helping them be
able to um to bring their imagination to
the future more
into the present and that's an
interesting one i think
can you say more about the um the
reception of this book are you getting
invited by
conservative groups as well as uh live
along now
i know i mean the book has been
tremendously successful but i i would i
would love to hear that you're getting
invited by all kinds of groups of
different backgrounds
yes i've talked to some private sector
groups and investors it's funny one of
the investment firms that i profiled
in the book eagle capital in new york
there's a sort of
there's a father and son who it's family
owned
investment firm that through long-term
approach has done wildly well like 25
billion
investment firm that had to really
withstand the noise and really resisted
the
the sort of allure of the first.com
bubble
and sort of the high prices that some of
those companies that were
that were a little more than froth were
trading at and the father
of the for the sort of like elder um
rather the firm his name is ravenel
curry um is
like doesn't really is not into doesn't
really buy
climate change as a big problem and and
then the younger one is
is sort of more um more on the same page
as i am
and um and yet like
he the elder guys like using this book
right
i'm in part because they're profiled on
the book but using it with all sorts of
companies and invest in investment
leaders and
um and i have been invited to different
kinds of venues to talk about the book i
think
it was a decision right like to i do
in the very in the preface i start by
writing about climate change because it
was a driver for me
to write the book and there was a
question of whether
that was a good thing to do
strategically for selling a book
that was raised by but i think my
literary agent
who first raised it and um
you know i think it's the big
long term thinking question of our time
is one of the biggest challenges we face
and i feel you can't talk about being a
good ancestor without thinking about
climate change so
um if there are people who don't invite
me to talk because
the book mentions climate change um
that's unfortunate but i just feel it's
so much more important that we
that we center it in our conversations
and in our in our thinking
for sure and i mean you you mentioned
how we tell ourselves stories and i i
i'm always kind of curious about how we
think about um
collective fiction things like science
fiction that you know in the 50s and 60s
was very
utopic and somewhere around the 70s in
blade runner it became very dystopic and
apocalyptic
and i wonder if these are um in a way
kind of a human
immune response to telling yourself
stories that we don't want to have
happen
but what's your take on science fiction
is it useful is it a is it a good space
for us to play
uh and learn yeah i mean i think it is
useful i
i think the dystopia the problem with
dystopia
it's useful it is useful for enhancing
our imaginations our ability to think
ahead but the challenge with
dystopic views of the future especially
when they become really popularized and
really
part of our uh of our conversation and
this is happening i think with climate
change to a degree
is that doomsday predictions have very
particular effects on human psychology
so you can raise the alarm if people get
really scared
it's good for sort of an immediate
reaction again to like have a sort of
um a hammer to hit at something uh when
you're afraid
but it's not so good for sustained
response and for sustained concern
and so uh the challenge i think with
some of the dystopic visions
particularly around climate change that
are becoming
part of the mainstream is that people
feel weak they feel like there's nothing
they can do
in light of these predictions of rising
seas of refugee crises
and uh when that happens you might just
decide to live like there's no tomorrow
to use that phrase um because you feel
powerless in face of that and i think
it's really important
uh not to be pollyanna and just believe
that the utopia is inevitable or that
the dystopia is inevitable but to really
see
the decision points we have to see the
agency we have as individuals and
collectively to shape the future for
better or worse
because that's the reality we face we
are not you know we are not
powerless in face of many of these
crises we have actual
ways in which we can either steer
steer the direction of our response to
the direction of
um of our societies and our
civilizations and
and i think dystopia is sort of like
disaster porn like it becomes a way of
sort of
um relegating our responsibility because
it's sort of
it's like okay the end is nigh
i'm just gonna you know have another
scotch
which you should do but not because the
end is nigh
but because you need to rest up for the
next day's
fight um we're we're wrapping up here
um but i i did want to ask um you know
after
um some you've had some of the more
amazing fellowships in
the united states and uh that helped you
write these this book
um which was great uh the numerica uh
fellowship and
the um and now you are an editor
uh a features editor at the boston globe
editorial page editorial page ever sorry
yeah the opinions
the about the features yeah but this has
put you into a uh
kind of a news cycle that is obviously a
very difficult
place to really think about the long
term and i'm i'm curious as to how that
transition is and
and then also you know are you going to
write um
the next book uh that's the that had
your original title
like there's no tomorrow i really
believe there's a tomorrow um so
uh i um
it's challenging being in a deadline
driven environment because and this is
uh i write about this
uh in the book in other contexts of of
businesses for example
um where if you're constantly up against
uh deadlines it becomes really it's
or firefighting as as some peop experts
call it
right it becomes very difficult to then
work on prevention of the fires or just
like what you want the new landscape to
look like
and uh the news industry is not only
like
you know i was last a journalist ten
years ago so i sort of left journalism
in a different era and then came back to
it uh
just a couple months ago and now it's
even more compressed with the 24 7 news
cycle i started the first day as the
public impeachment trial
so there hasn't been a dull moment since
i arrived back in the newsroom
and it does become really hard to plan
for
like what is the future of opinion
journalism like we're
the business model of journalism has
been totally shaken up
uh everyone has an opinion everyone can
tweet their opinion
and share it online so what's the value
of a newspaper well part of it is that
we have trained people who are fact
checking
we you know there's this credibility
factor where we're really kind of
building something that has more rigor
in terms of opinion
and then we also can curate like we can
have right like we can bring in voices
and
and try to figure out which voices we
want to amplify in this time
and so yeah what i'm trying to do now is
really
think of think about how to do that
while also doing all this daily stuff
and it's a big challenge
and so part of the job is just like
figuring out how to free up some of my
bandwidth to do that
and to to be thinking ahead more like
stuff like you know how which people you
put on which kind of
stories and how you um preserve some
thinking time you know i have
like a day a week where like a saturday
morning where i feel like it's really
important to get out into nature go out
to walden pond and walk around while the
pond and just
scan literally scan the horizon but also
figuratively scan it for
um what's beyond the immediate well
that's a great plug
our next talk at the intervals with
tiffany schlain whose book 24
6 is about taking 24 hours off every
week off of
uh technology and screens which i would
also recommend so it'll be
it's the next step in the personal
long-term thinking thing
but uh um it's it's a good one and that
also really helps with writing a book
to get off the device yeah um yeah i
always find when the internet stops in
our office like it's amazing how many
things people have to do
all of a sudden yeah all this filing
right um there was a there was an idea
we'll just close with this is um
that i was really struck and i was kind
of amazed that i had never
uh i had never heard of edith brown
weiss and her
principal around intergenerational
equity and it was like this kind of
light of hope in my head than something
that i had to dive into and research
some more so
if you just explain that principle sure
yeah so edith brown weiss is a
georgetown law scholar and uh
she did she coined this term and this
concept of intergenerational equity
which he says is actually built into a
lot of
founding documents so this idea that the
next generation matters and we should do
something for future generations and i
kind of went deeper into this as well
is you know edmund burke who's the
godfather of conservatism the irish
political philosopher wrote about
society as a partnership among
generations
thomas jefferson wrote to james madison
talking about
how resources should be unencumbered for
future generations
by their predecessors
teddy roosevelt wrote about this concept
so
and it's also in the public trust
doctrine which exists in
a number of constitutions across
different continents different countries
and it's this idea that uh
that the next generation matters and and
why is even brown weiss's concept of it
is that it can really be built into law
that actually there are cases where
decisions
are being made like the indian supreme
court has made a couple decisions
where essentially they've said this coal
company
can't do build this plant because of
intergenerational equity issues
basically because this
would be harmful to the next generation
and there are some lawsuits that are
working their way through the federal
courts in this country
and other countries as well to try to
establish this idea
that you can actually future generations
can actually be
represented in our legal system and that
they have
rights and the way that that's been
playing out
mostly is to have young people as part
of the plaintiffs
the group of plaintiffs for these
lawsuits but they're also
in a way in a sense they're representing
unborn generations right they're
representing themselves
but a lot of these harms particularly
with climate change play out over the
course of many generations and so
the the young people alive today are
almost like stand-ins for
future young people which is really kind
of cool and there are ways that
uh parliaments in israel and finland
have even created ombuds people for
future generations so there's ways in
which institutions
can actually reflect this idea of
intergenerational equity
uh within them and um you know we're not
in the most
um bright spot in our politics to
institute something like this right now
but i think these ideas really matter
and
as we think about what what is the
government what is the society that we
want in the future what do we want it to
look like how do we want
to rebuild this democracy in particular
i think these ideas really are going to
matter
well here's to the next generation
having legal rights
thank you very much
[Music]
you